I'm Jennifer Willis I'm a science writer
like my job here is primarily to listen
and learn and ask the occasional
questions okay but in many respects I
feel at home here because I'm very much
like a lot of the people at this table
most of us it seems like have a very
interdisciplinary background just
because we didn't know what we wanted to
be will be grew up very much appreciated
what Rebecca was talking about about
libraries being dangerous places because
like her I grew up in a very religious
family in this case an evangelical
religious family and ironically because
you know my dad had been the first
member of his family to go to college
and he got a good job as a result he
thought his kids should learn so they
did value education they hadn't quite
thought that through they didn't really
understand what education was it wasn't
just a job training and so they didn't
seem to think there was anything wrong
with me reading all these books but of
course I got exposed to ideas that they
never in a million years would have told
me my tastes were not as highbrow as a
Rebecca's I did not stumble on the story
of the atom make the big story that
changed my life when I was like eight or
nine years old with a horror story that
I found in this Alfred Hitchcock
anthology called yours truly Jack the
river what was shocking about it was
like it was written in the first person
and they the sky is trying to help
detective find Jack the Ripper at the
very last paragraph you find out that
the narrator is Jack the Ripper it was
my first encounter with the unreliable
narrator and so of course as as someone
who loved reading and writing I you know
I like that about my crowd but it's more
important because from a child's
perspective up to that point and just
believe what people tell you and when
you're being told you know about God and
and the Bible and all these sorts of
things it does not occur to you that
someone might not be a reliable narrator
so for me I was already beginning to
have doubts because you know I couldn't
speak in tongues no matter how hard I
tried and I just you just get just did
not make any sense to me
you know that this world that I found
myself raised in to realize that perhaps
I was being told the wrong story that
perhaps I was be
told something that wasn't true and it
took many many years after that to get
me to the to to a level of naturalism
that eventually I could get there and I
credit voracious reading in the public
libraries with it with being a very key
part of that I was an English major I
ended up becoming a science writer
specializing in physics Sean and I like
to joke that he covers the very big and
the very small and I like all the messy
stuff in between like materials and
phase transitions and thermodynamics and
all those sorts of things and I'm very
interested in the questions of
complexity and consciousness among other
things so it's interesting I am NOT
while I am an atheist I am NOT
particularly involved in in being a
public atheist for me many of the
discussions that surround science and
religion that take place on the broad
public sphere are not very interesting
to me it ends up rehashing the same old
arguments nobody changes their minds
that sort of thing this sort of
conference interests me a great deal
because I'm looking I'm looking at a
bunch of people who thought very deeply
about very important issues all of whom
apparently are at least willing to
consider changing their minds and that
alone makes it a wonderful experience
for me it's a it's a privilege as a
science writer to be able to interact
and listen in on some of these
conversations from my own part you know
I
you could probably change my mind about
anything because any opinions I have on
this never very very preliminary and new
but I am very much interested one thing
you might not be able to convince me of
it would be very difficult to convince
me of is this notion of you know the
self as a as a in consciousness as an
emergent phenomenon I see a lot of stuff
being bandied about these days you know
with books and articles and things about
this means that the self is an illusion
I simply don't accept that I come from a
physics perspective emergence is real a
traffic jam is emergent but it is
nonetheless real so I'd be very
interested if someone wants to argue for
the illusion thing I'd be interested in
hearing about it
you